monday
corporate
et
renvoyer ago famille tous les détails
qui nous ont demandés nous sommes
convaincus que égouts famille dispose
désormais de toutes les informations
nécessaires pour lever immédiatement la
suspension qu'ils ont imposée à notre
campagne j'espère avoir une belle de
goût fanmi bientôt afin que nous
puissions acheminer l'argent aux
camionneurs il faire avancer notre
protestation pour la liberté
plus de 10 millions de dollars c'est ce
qu'à ramasser canada unity à travers le
soutien au financement de gauffeny on a
libéré un million chez hugo fonds ni
pour les manifestations le reste est
gelée et aujourd'hui la chambre des
communes une motion a été adoptée c'est
celle du npd le bloc celle du bloc a
prêté accepter monsieur le npd a été
accepté aux communes pour demander à
l'organisation go faune me d'enquêter
sur l'origine et l'utilisation des fonds
on veut qu'ils répondent aux questions
on veut qu'il y ait transparence parce
que il ya peut-être des danger en la
demeure je fais le point avec david
morin professeur à l'université de
sherbrooke et co titulaire de la chaire
unesco en prévention de la
radicalisation de l'écran de
l'extrémisme violent bonsoir david morin
mon rendement écoutez donc ces gens là
vont créer une une
une organisation à but non lucratif pour
utiliser les 10 millions de dollars êtes
vous surpris par l'ampleur que ça a pris
hélas le recours qu'ils vont exercer
pour mettre la main sur sur l'argent
ah oui écoutez on va pas se cacher que
quelques quelques jours une dizaine de
semaines maximum récolté 10 millions de
dollars avoir plus que cent vingt mille
donateurs
c'est quand même considérable en tout
cas écoutez je suis pas un spécialiste
de golf en demies mais je pense qu'au
canada c'est une des grosses collectes
de fonds donc ça c'est pas très
surprenant c'est pas très surprenant non
plus que goff en demi et gelé
temporairement les fonds pour examiner
un peu ce qui ce qui te passe plus en
détail compte tenu des sommes
conséquentes et de la nature du
mouvement politique aussi qui est en
train de s'installer à ottawa est ce que
c'est mais s'est révélé quelques jours
que grande partie des donateurs étaient
anonymes
on soupçonne même qui a un financement
qui vient de l'étranger la première idée
qui nous vient là c'est un peu à la
lumière de ce qui s'est passé aux états
unis avec trump qui ramassent des
millions qui peut y avoir du financement
qui vient de
la tendance trump est ce qui vient
d'ailleurs de tous ceux qui peuvent
avoir intérêt à perturber une démocratie
une vie démocratique non oui écouter ce
serait pas très étonnant on va attendre
d'en savoir un peu plus mais
effectivement on sait aussi que entre la
droite canadienne donc qui est quand
même l'organisatrice du convoi à ottawa
même si tous les gens qui y ont
participé sont pas nécessairement de
cette mouvance la l'organisation
clairement elle et elle est associée à
ça
est quand même assez inspiré de l'
approche américaine pour ce type de
mouvements là le financement etc on sait
qu'il ya aussi des liens entre la halle
trike canadienne et la droite américaine
donc ça serait tout à fait plausible
effectivement que il est pas mal de
financement qui viennent de là on a vu
également aussi dans la manifestation à
ottawa un certain nombre de drapeaux que
ce soit des drapeau confédéré que ce
soit les drapeaux libertariens je pense
notamment à cela parce qu'on avait quand
même un certain nombre donc ce n'est pas
impossible que ce soit finalement des
citoyens américains également qui est
passé la frontière et qu'ils soient
venus un peu garni finalement les rangs
du mouvement de contestation à ottawa
donc effectivement il ya ici des
questions à se poser on avait quelques
groupes qui sont notamment moi j'ai vu
deux trois drapeaux d'être hyper centers
donc cette milice américaine bien connue
qui a notamment souvent servi de service
d'ordre aux manifestations de la nature
est américaine qui a été ajouté sur la
liste des entités terroristes par le
canada assez récemment en raison de sa
présence dans l'assaut du 6 janvier
avéré avec deux trois autres grosses
l'organisation dans les plus brefs dont
on a déjà parlé donc admettons qu'ils
aient ce genre de groupes là qui
effectivement donne de l'argent pourrait
y avoir effectivement du financement qui
serait totalement illégale donc là
encore ce sont des hypothèses donc il
faut pas sauter aux conclusions tout de
suite mais en même temps on a tellement
transparence des partis politiques je
pense au québec le domaine maximum ses
100 dollars maintenant après les travaux
la commission charbonneau à ottawa c'est
un peu plus mon exige la transparence
pour le financement des partis
politiques est il si on est en présence
d'une organisation qui est obscur qui
ramassent des fonds dont on connaît pas
la provenance et qui pourrait les
investir dans des manifestations contre
les institutions parce que ce qu'on veut
c'est la levée des mesures sanitaires on
veut même déposé jeudi sa décision le
gouvernement sait c'est que ces gens-là
exprime à ottawa oui tout à fait c'est
discours derrière ça on pourrait aussi
avoir du financement qui viennent
d'autres pays et pas juste des états
unis ce qu'on sait qu'on a quand même
quelques pays qui font de l'ingérence
dans les affaires démocratique des
sociétés occidentales on pense par
exemple à la russie là je fais bien
attention ne pourra accuser évidemment
la russie puisque on n'a pas de preuves
en l'état mais écoutez on a déjà vu
effectivement des usines à troll essayé
sur les réseaux sociaux d'ajouter du
bruit au bruit alors comprenez moi bien
on n'a pas besoin des russes ou
d'ingérence étrangère actuellement pour
déstabiliser nous mêmes le système
démocratique avec ces mouvements là mais
oui on pourrait aussi imaginer que la
veillée du financement qui proviennent
de ce type de pays donc c'est assez
c'est assez complexe je pense que c'est
surtout dans les semaines et les mois à
venir qui va falloir continuer d'être
extrêmement vigilant pour exiger de
l'organisation qu'elle explique où sont
allés les fonds si d'aventuré
effectivement gauche en 2000 et libère
et que là il est effectivement un suivi
qui soit très très serré ne serait-ce
que aussi pour les gens qui donnent
l'argent parce qu'on a déjà vu ce genre
de fondation et là j'en ai quelques unes
en tête notamment au québec récolter de
l'argent et puis finalement dire que
c'était pour refaire à et puis
finalement s'en servir pour faire tout
autre chose donc il faut pas non plus
que les gens qui ont donné soit abusé
donc effectivement là il ya un
dispositif de vigilance à mettre en
place est d'autant que le gouvernement
canadien le parlement devra faire vite
si le convoi de la liberté espère mettre
la main sur les souder lundi en
transigeant avec vos fans me laver les
entendre
oui et puis je pense qu'effectivement
compte tenu de la situation actuelle il
faut se il faut se dépêcher
d'accélérer effectivement d'avènement
rien merci beaucoup d'avoir est avec moi
ce soir à bientôt ça me fait plaisir je
souhaite une bonne journée pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit
[Musique]